So, right here I have regular Claude
code building me a plan, and it's been
running for almost 4 minutes now. And in
this terminal, I have it doing the exact
same plan, but now it's doing it with
ultra plan mode. You can see it says
monitor progress in Claude code on the
web, and right here it says ultra plan
ready. So, if I hover on that, click
enter, I'm able to review this on the
web, and this finished in about 1
minute, whereas this one is still
running, and it's been over 4 minutes
now. And when I go to that web session,
we can see the actual plan. I have
context, I have what already exists, the
new approach with new files to be made,
modifications, as well as just a final
verification. This gives me the plan in
a lot more structured way. I also
sometimes get diagrams based on what
it's actually planning. And in here, I
can go ahead and leave emoji reactions
on certain places, which I think is a
nice touch, or I could go ahead and
comment on specific elements, as you can
see right here, I could add a comment.
And then, when I want to send these
comments off, Claude will go back and do
another iteration of the plan, or I
could click on this button, which is
approve plan and teleport back to the
terminal. So, I do that, and now it's
going to send it back. And if I jump
back into that session right here, we
can now see the plan has been received,
and we can either implement it here, or
we could start a new conversation and
implement it there. So, if I just click
on this, now we have that full plan that
Claude code on the web actually built
for us, and it's being worked on right
here locally. And the whole time this
original section is still planning, it's
still asking me questions, and it's just
moving very slow. Now, I'm not saying
that speed is always the most important
thing, but if you're getting speed and
higher quality, then that is a good
combination. Now, what else you'll
notice is in this session of the cloud
where it sends off my prompt to be ultra
planned, it's still able to look what's
inside of our directory because it syncs
to Git. So, right here it starts off by
exploring what's in the directory to see
what it can build on, and it was able to
find existing skills and scripts, and
just able to leverage those and use
those in the plan. So, basically, this
is all thanks to the new kind of secret
feature called ultra plan. Plan in the
cloud with ultra plan, you start a plan
from your CLI, you draft it on the web,
and then you send it back to the
terminal, or you can just execute it
remotely as well. And it's really
interesting, I've ran a ton of different
tests between the same prompts locally
and the same prompts to be ultra
planned, and not only is ultra plan
faster at planning, but for some reason
it's much faster at executing, too. And
I think it's just because the plan is so
clear that the agents have a much easier
time locally just executing on it and
building everything out. And I'll show
you guys an example of that in a bit.
This is useful when you want a richer
review surface than what the terminal
offers as far as targeted feedback,
because you can comment on individual
sections. You get a nice sort of like
doc style plan as well, rather than in
the terminal, sometimes it can just be
like lines of text, so it's kind of
messy to see like the structure. You
also have hands-off drafting, and you
have flexible execution. So, it's really
simple, you just do a  ultra
plan, and then your prompt, or if you
just have the word ultra plan in there,
it will ask you if you want to ultra
plan. So, if I just come back in here,
and you see I literally just type the
word ultra plan, it lights up the same
way that it would light up if you do
something like ultra think. So, maybe
you ultra think and ultra plan, you burn
through your entire session in one
prompt. Because obviously, the ultra
plan is using a little bit more tokens,
I'll show you guys an example of that
later. We don't know exactly how many,
but the way that it's spinning up and
it's using a lot more compute resources
in the cloud, it's going to use more
tokens than if you just do a regular
plan over here. But once again, planning
is so, so important, it sets the whole
structure and path of your project on
the right path. So, sometimes it really
is worth spending more tokens up front
in order to shoot it off. I always think
of this quote by Abraham Lincoln, "Give
me 6 hours to chop down a tree, and I
will spend the first four sharpening the
axe." So, that's basically our planning.
Also important to know that this has to
be done in the CLI. If we are here in
the desktop app and we tried to do
something like ultra plan, build me a
5-day workout guide, if we shoot this
off, we're not going to get that whole
ultra plan in the cloud functionality.
In fact, it actually just doesn't do
anything. And same exact thing if we hop
over to VS code, if we're doing it in
the extension rather than in the
terminal, ultra plan, and then we just
let's just copy in the exact same thing,
it's basically just going to do nothing.
So, you have to use it in the CLI. Okay,
so quick explanation of how this
actually works, and then we're going to
jump into an actual example that I ran
and show you guys what it looks like.
So, so we start talking to Claude code
on our machine. Push an ultra plan, it
sends that to the cloud, where that's
where Claude will spin up, you know,
different agents there using Opus, and
it will do a really in-depth plan. Once
that's ready, we're able to review, and
we have this kind of feedback loop, but
then we can teleport it all the way back
to our machine if we want that to happen
there. Like I said, you can launch it by
doing  ultra plan, you can just
have the keyword in there, or you could,
you know, from an existing plan, like
you already have one written up in
locally, you could say, "Actually, I
want to revise this in the cloud with
ultra plan." And then, of course, you
have that review loop, you can do
comments, and you can do emojis, which
is a nice touch. All right, so let me
show you guys an example of this. So, I
have ultra plan on the right, I have a
regular plan on the left, and I gave
both of these a huge spec about building
us a dashboard. So, I used ultra plan
over here, pasted it in, I said, "Do not
use superpower skill," because I didn't
want the local version to use that, I
wanted it to just get raw, you know,
keep the variables the same, and then I
wanted to give it to us on a local host.
So, I'm going to shoot this off, you see
on the right-hand side, it says, "Do you
want to do this in the cloud?" I said,
"Yes." On the left-hand side, it just
goes straight into plan mode. And once
again, they got the exact same prompts.
So, here is the link, I open this up,
and it takes me to the cloud, where it's
actually going to start building out the
plan right here, as you can see. It's
checking the directory to see what's
available, and then over here, it's
just, you know, kind of doing the same
thing, getting acclimated with the
environment. Okay, so at this point,
we're about 2 minutes in, right? And you
can see that I got the plan already on
this right-hand side. So, I click
through it a bit, we have different
tabs, we also have like a little
diagram, and it looks really good. So,
what I do is I end up sending this back
to the terminal, as you can see right
here, and then it gets brought back into
our local session right here. Okay, so
now we're at the 14-minute mark, and the
ultra plan version already done. The
local host is spun up, so not only did
it create the plan, but it also built
everything out, whereas this regular
plan mode has been going for 12 minutes
and still hasn't even given me a plan to
review yet. And finally, a few minutes
later, we're at the 15-minute mark, this
is when we actually finally get the plan
from the local session. But you can see
at the 26, 27-minute mark, it is still
being built out. So, I end up stopping
this recording to just wait until it's
actually done. So, now I'm going to
switch over to the actual live reaction
of me looking at the differences in the
two dashboards to see which one really
built it out better. Okay, so just the
regular plan mode is finally done. It's
really weird, I I normally stand in
these videos, but I had to sit because
this took, honestly, like 45 minutes.
I'm not sure what was going on, but this
thing on the right side, we did ultra
plan, the plan finished in like five,
and then it executed everything and
built everything in, you know, like
another 5 minutes, so about 10 to 15
minutes total over here.
And on this side, it literally took half
the time to plan and then half the time
to build, like it took a long time. So,
anyways, we have the two dashboards
here, let's open up the
regular plan mode dashboard. So, let me
open this up, you can see we have our
pulse board, we have a nice little
graphic here, we have some stats like
MRR, annual run rate, total customers,
churn rate. We can change this between
all time, 30 days, 90 days, 6 months, 1
year. We have different tabs on the
left, we can do revenue
and see different tiers, we can also see
enterprise and pro, top 20 accounts,
obviously all this is mock data. We've
got our customers here with a nice chart
and by tier, and then we have support.
So, resolution time, tickets by
category, distribution, we can do light
mode or dark mode, and that all looks
pretty decent. These charts look a
little bit weird in light mode, but
anyways,
that is the plan version. Let's open up
the ultra plan version
on a different local host. This one,
obviously, they're going to have very
similar features as far as what we're
looking at with the data, similar
statistics up here, um similar charts,
everything like that. If we go to 30
days, 90 days, 6 months, 1 year, that
all loads in good. If we go down to
revenue, we can see we also have a
cohort retention, we have enterprise and
pro, and we got some our 20 accounts
there.
Customers, obviously, we've got the same
exact type of layout
and the support
over here. If we go to light mode, let's
see what these look like.
These all still look very, very solid.
So, I mean, it's not a huge difference,
right? And for something like a
dashboard like this from an aesthetic
point of view, it's kind of hard to tell
like which one objectively between these
two did better. If we wanted to look at
things like
how accurate the data's being pulled in
or reflected, or how quick things load
up, or how buggy it is, we'd have to do
some deeper investigating, but also take
a look at this. In the local plan
version, it took 131,000 tokens, the
ultra plan version took 82,000 tokens.
Now, of course, the bulk of the planning
work was done in the cloud, so those
tokens don't count. You guys saw earlier
when I was doing this, this is the
section where we did our ultra plan on
the web, and I tried to run a
cost to see how much this took, but it
wasn't working, so we don't know
exactly. But I will say it's using more
tokens than the local, so it looks like
this is using 50,000 more tokens. I'm
assuming that the planning section for
the ultra plan took at least 50K, but
it's hard for me to say exactly. But I
think that the plan was so much better
because for some reason it was able to
execute on the plan so much quicker and
better, and they were both using,
obviously, the exact same model. And all
the other tests that I've done, ultra
plan has always been quicker. I mean, in
the cloud, there's so much more compute
compared to what might be going on here
on my device.
But yeah, like this was a noticeable
difference, not only with the plan, but
when it came to the actual execution.
Like I said, the execution over here was
maybe maybe 10 minutes, the execution
over here was upwards of 30 minutes.
Okay, so I tried running some
experiments for you guys. I did a
session with API billing, and I ran a
local plan, as you can see, and this
ended up costing me about 1.5 million
tokens in and 23,000 tokens out, and a
mix between Haiku and Opus. Now,
unfortunately, it doesn't let you do the
ultra plan with API billing because you
need basically a pro or max subscription
in order to do the Claude code on the
web. I tried, it wasn't letting me do
that. So anyways, I did do this though.
When it came back, what I did is I just
checked how much of my usage did it
actually go up, and it went up 1%. So we
don't have an explicit number of tokens
that we get allotted within this max 20x
plan. So I don't know how many exact
tokens it was, but I'm going to estimate
that it was more than 1.5 in and 23,000
out, and it was about 1% of my 20x max
plan. So hopefully that gives you guys a
little bit of context and just at least
gives you a nice baseline. Okay, so
let's talk about a few other things that
you need to know about how this works
under the hood and what you need to
know. So first I'm going to start off
with like
your project, if you want to ultra plan,
it has to have some sort of Git or
GitHub, you know, repo synced to it
because it has to be pushed to the cloud
somehow. So if you try to run ultra plan
in a project that's only local, it's
going to say, "Hey, you can't do this on
the web yet." It's as simple as just
initializing that Git, pushing it, super
easy, and then you can do it because
obviously in the cloud, when it's doing
the ultra plan, it needs to look through
everything that you have and it needs to
be able to actually work on your code
base. Otherwise, it's going to be a
very, very generic plan.
Now after that, sometimes I've noticed
that it's not calling my skills. Even
though it looks through, the skills are
things that get invoked. So if you're
not specific enough on your plan for the
ultra plan, then it may not use the
skills the first time. And actually all
of these visualizations here that I
made, I made using ultra plan. So I'll
put up a clip here where I'm showing how
that worked. And what you'll notice is
that I had to give it correction on
using
my visualization skill because it wasn't
pulling that up for some reason.
Okay, so here is that clip now. It says,
"I want you to ultra plan and research
cloud code's new feature ultra plan."
And I kept saying ultra plan because I
love when it when it lights up like
that. But anyways, we shot this off,
right? And it goes to the web, and now
it's doing a fetch on our project and
getting an understanding of what we want
it to do.
But what you'll notice here is that it
doesn't actually create the Excalidraw
style diagrams using my visualization
skill, which uses Nano Banana, and it
has like a prompting guide and a style
guide, but it thought that I just wanted
like markdown um you know, mermaid style
diagrams, which is what it built as you
can see here. So I realized that it was
creating these not the right way. I
added a comment right here that says,
"Hey, I already have a skill set up that
does this, so I want you to do it that
way." And then when I shoot off that
comment, it basically comes back and
says, "Okay, I didn't see that skill.
What's the name of that skill?" So I had
to tell it explicitly right here which
is the skill that it's looking for. So
it asked me this question, and then I
say it's called visualizations. And then
once I said that, it was able to find it
and it was able to use it, which is
good. But just something to keep in
mind, even though it can see your whole
project, sometimes you still have to
prompt it in the right way. And once
again, this is just in research preview.
Anyways, then it came back the right
way, so I sent it back to the terminal,
and then I was able to actually have
everything be built out from my session
here because the plan had been approved,
and then I just go ahead and implement
it locally. Okay, so now let's talk
about what is actually happening because
we're sending it to the cloud and it
only works in the cloud. So that makes
you think, "Why?" So obviously it's
getting more compute, but I wanted to
understand why and like what that even
means. So I had this agent here do a
deep dive into the ultra plan feature.
It looked at source code, it looked at
community forums, and it looked at the
actual documentation. And here's what it
came up with.
Ultra plan offloads your planning
session to a cloud-hosted instance
running Opus 4.6. It uses multi-agent
exploration to build a deeper plan than
the local mode can. Then it either
executes in the cloud or it goes back to
your terminal. So what I thought was
interesting is the multi-agent
exploration. So here's a quick
comparison table. When you do local
plan, it runs in your terminal. When you
do ultra plan, it runs in Anthropic's
cloud container runtime.
The model is whatever session you're
using. Ultra plan always uses Opus 4.6.
The planning approach is a single agent
and it's linear thinking, whereas ultra
plan is multi-agent. It is three
parallel exploration agents plus one
critique agent. So obviously this is
going to use more tokens, but like we
talked about, if you use more tokens up
front, it's definitely worth it if it's,
you know, faster and higher quality. Now
the max compute time over here is
bounded by your session, but on the
cloud, it's 30 minutes as a cap. I've
never hit that and I don't think I will
because of how quick it's been, but
there is a cap on it there. Now the
other interesting thing is your terminal
gets blocked while you're in plan mode
because your session is focusing on
that. But in ultra plan, if you send
your plan to the web, you can continue
talking to that terminal session and
wait for it to get teleported back. Now
truthfully, I don't know exactly when I
would do that. I'd probably just spin up
a different session because I'd want to
keep that context clean so that I can
just execute when it comes back, but
that is something that is a difference.
And then the review interface, you
basically get text dialogue in your
terminal. If you're using VS Code with
cloud code and you're using like this
extension rather than the terminal, then
you do get a nice like doc and it looks
a little bit better. You can leave
comments on it, but if you're not using
that and you're using the terminal, then
it's definitely going to be better in
the ultra plan version. And really the
only requirement here is that you have
to have it synced to some sort of repo
so that cloud code with your web account
can actually log in and look at your
project before it starts planning things
out. So I'm sure that this is going to
evolve as more people use it, as more
people start to give feedback about it.
Um when I was testing it out, I did run
into a few issues where I was getting
this authentication error. I'm not sure
if that was something internal or
something I did wrong, but it just
seemed to pop up randomly and then I'd
run it again and it'd be fine. But it
also seems like we'll start to get more
clarity around how exactly this works
soon, why it's so much better at
executing, so much faster, and the fact
that these are parallel exploration
agents. So I'd be curious how they're
prompted differently so they're not just
duplicating work, or maybe they are,
maybe that's the point. Um I don't
assume that this is some sort of agent
team that they can talk to each other
and share a task list. And what I'd be
curious to know is
if we could get more visibility on how
many tokens are actually being used in
that plan. But yeah, it would be nice to
be able to see, "Hey, the ultra plan is
finished, and by the way, here's how
many tokens it just ran." Anyways, that
is going to do it for this one. So if
you guys enjoyed the video or learned
something new, please give it a like, it
helps me out a ton. And as always, I
appreciate you guys making it to the end
of the video. I'll see you on the next
one.
Thanks, everyone.